. Herzlich willkommen zu das Podcast-Ufo DPU. Das ist der Podcast, den ihr gerne hört, sonst hättet ihr ja wohl nicht draufgeklickt. Vielen Dank für dieses fantastische Intro von Kim. Es ist immer schön, wenn die Intros ungefähr zwei Jahre früher eingesendet wurden und sich auf Dinge in Folgen beziehen, die wir vor zwei Jahren gesagt haben. Oder von noch davor sogar, wo man noch nicht ahnte, dass wir Reggaeton irgendwann mal durch den Kakao ziehen, wie man das ja von uns kennt. Wir ziehen ja Dinge durch den Kakao. Auch eine spannende Redensart. Meine alte Nemesis, dieser Beat, ist zurückgekehrt. Und ich finde es auch gut, dass man, weil immer wenn man eine Sprache anfängt zu lernen, ist man eigentlich direkt schon in einem schlechten Gewissen drin, dass man nicht genug lernt. Wie du zum Beispiel, hast du in letzter Zeit Japanisch gelernt? Kein bisschen, ich habe alles wieder vergessen dafür, aber aktiv vergessen. Und hat Spanisch auch noch mitunter gezogen. Ja, habe ich auch noch vergessen. Ich habe hierbei jetzt weniger Spanisch, weil ich angefangen habe, Japanisch zu lernen. Du machst ja Platz im Kopf, immer wenn was Neues kommt. Ist das so? Ich weiß nicht, wie ihr Körper funktionieren. Wir müssen nur zwei Prozent unserer Gehirnmasse. Warum muss man den Platz schaffen? Nee, der Kopf sagt, nee, komm, das ganze Alter hier, Stochastik kann raus, Analyse, das brauchst du nicht mehr.
Im Erster Weltkrieg, reicht, wenn ich den Zweiten weiss, raus damit. Aber gibt es da auch solche und solche Gehirne oder sind alle Gehirne da gleich? Weil es gibt ja auch Leute, die zu Hause eher sammeln, Dinge kaufen, sich nicht gut von denen trennen können. Ich frage mich, ob es bei Gehirnen auch so ist, ob es auch so Gehirne gibt, die sich schlecht von Spanisch trennen können, sehr schlecht von binomischen Formeln zum Beispiel trennen können. Mein Gehirn kann sich sehr gut trennen von Dingen, mein Gehirn, der sagt, raus! Du, das Gehirn ist ein Muskel und Muskel, wenn du nicht benutzt, baut er auch ab, vielleicht. Ja, ich benutze ihn ja, aber andere Teile des Gehirns. Ja, der Gehirn besteht aus ganz vielen Muskeln. Wenn man sich das Gehirn vorstellt, das hat so viele Wölbungen, das ist alles ein schöner Bizeps, der richtig schön angespannt ist. Und wenn der nicht mehr gefordert wird, dann sagt er, ich gehe nach Hause, Freund, ich packe es. Stefan, wir sind wieder früh am Morgen, du schlürfst, schön dein Tee, es ist die Erkältungsphase. Ja, letztes Mal habe ich Leute Freunde angelogen, weil ich gesagt habe, ich muss noch einen Podcast aufnehmen. Da haben die einen Podcast gehört, in dem wir lauthals verkünden, dass wir morgens aufnehmen. Wir müssen das dringend aufhören. Ich dachte, du hättest Leuten gesagt, dass du krank bist und musst jetzt einen Podcast so tun. So, ich kann mich gerade hierher geschlägt. Nein, ich habe gesagt, ich hatte Abend da, wir müssen noch einen Podcast aufnehmen und so. Und das ist mittlerweile bei vielen Bekannten von mir eine gut funktionierende Ausrede., weil es immer heißt, ja gut, die machst du ja jede Woche, klar, die musst du ja auch diese Woche machen, keine Chance, dann treffen wir uns halt morgen. Und ich habe die Ausrede benutzt und ich wurde enttarnt, weil wir lauter halt sagen, so früh morgens. Oh, sieben Uhr vierzig, oh, sieben Uhr vierzig am Dienstag. Genau heute, der 22. November. Okay, dann schliessen wir ab jetzt den Pakt ab, wir reden nie wieder über Aufnahmezeit und Tag. Angenommen wir haben einen Mord vor, so, kann ja mal passieren, weiss man ja jetzt noch nicht, dann ist es total blöd, dass wir hier immer die Uhrzeit verkünden laut. Ja, dann würden wir gerade die Uhrzeit verkünden, dann würden wir sagen, Mittwoch 16.30 Uhr und genau da findet der Mord statt. Und dann natieren wir den zurück. Ja. Kann man glaube ich nicht. Ja, aber es ist genau das Problem, dass uns deswegen vielleicht nicht sagen, dass es heute Mittwoch oder nur 20 ist. Ja, finde ich gut. Es ist so ein bisschen wie der Pakt, immer wenn Leute fragen, und ist derjenige gerade bei dir, immer Ja zu sagen. Immer Ja sagen, ja. Oder immer Nein, je nachdem, ich weiß auch nicht genau. Aber irgendwie ist es nicht so gute Freundin. Wenn die Freundin fragt, hey, ist der gerade bei dir, dann sagt man ja. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich bin in solchen zwischenmenschlichen Dingen sehr schlecht. Nicht antworten einfach. Ich habe bei WhatsApp jetzt auch ausgestellt, dass man sieht, ob ich die Nachricht gelesen habe. Nee, das finde ich feige. Das finde ich feige. Ich finde, es ist klar, soziale Miteinander ist ein Schlachtfeld, aber ich finde, man darf sich da auch nicht völlig zurechtfinden. Ja, das ist ein Schlachtfeld und das ist für mich so ein Rückzugsort, wie so einen kleinen Bunker, den ich wieder gebaut habe, aber mitten auf dem Flachtwelt. Nee, das ist feige, das ist feige. Warum? Du musst da schon mitmachen. Das habe ich auch gestellt. Das macht es interessanter, das ist wie wenn du überhaupt nicht mehr teilnimmst. Das macht schon Sinn, ehrlich gesagt. Stell dir vor, es ist WhatsApp und keiner geht hin. Ehrlich gesagt, stehe ich mir sowas paradiesvoll ein bisschen. Ja, ein bisschen. Weil es auch große Skandale zum Thema WhatsApp-Gruppen bei Schülern. Also auch bei meiner alten Schule gab es einen Artikel in der Lokalpresse, volksverhetzende Nachrichten in WhatsApp-Gruppen gefunden. Aber auch in Südterlin noch geschrieben, das klingt auch wieder nah. Und irgendwelche Neunklässler posten irgendwelche Hitler-Vergleiche oder irgendwie sowas in WhatsApp-Gruppen. Und ein großer Skandal, weil jede, tatsächlich 95 Prozent aller Schulklassen hat eine eigene WhatsApp-Gruppe, wo die Klasse innerhalb der Klasse Sachen rotieren lässt und natürlich großer Gruppenzwang, ja, wenn du der einzige der bist, der nicht dabei ist, hast du ein Problem, musst dabei sein, die Zehnjährigen wollen schon ein Smartphone haben, um in der Gruppe zu sein und dann kriegst du da ständig irgendwie Pornos. Pornos? Ja, habe ich auch gelesen, es stand dann auch so, ja, in irgendeiner Oberstufengruppe wurden Pornos gefunden, der Rektor stellte Strafverzeige. Aber ich auch dachte, komm mal. Bei uns hat damals noch der Hausmeister mit seiner Frau Pornos-Bornos im Lüge. Klar, natürlich. Das war noch unsere Zeit. Das war die erste Bezugsquelle für Pornos, wo du irgendwie so eine verschmachtelte VHS--Kassette bekommen, wo du es dann nochmal überträgst oder so. Ja. Wo einfach mal die ganze Schule sich von einer VHS-Kassotte den Porno gezogen hat, die am Ende total abgefrippelt war. War Kassotte der Vorgänger der Kassette eigentlich? Damals ja. Wie MP2, MP3, MP4, immer besser. Musik. Aber auch da ist es halt immer schwer, zwischen Gag und Realität zu trennen. Ich meine, da gibt es ja auch Humor erlebt ja von Grenzübertretungen und dann waren da so Beispiele, was da so gepostet wird. So und dann weiß man nicht, ist es jetzt echter Rassismus oder einfach ein geschmackloser Gag? Schwer nicht zu sagen, hätte man damals alles dokumentiert, was man damals so gesagt hätte? Weiß ich nicht. Es ist wirklich interessant. Ich habe da auch große Probleme mit solchen Gruppen, wo dann teilweise Witze gemacht werden. Vor allem auch so aus Gruppen, in deren Blasen man ja eigentlich gar nicht mehr so ist. Ich habe noch so eine alte Universitätsgruppe, wo auch Leute drin sind, wo man sich auch fragt. Nuss, Vorsichtig bitte. Okay, wir müssen... Wir müssen transparent machen, dass wir gerade zweimal einfach abgewürgt wurden.
Wir haben die Folgestellung jetzt...
Wir streiten schon acht Stunden neben mir schon auf.
Und gerade hat Führung gemerkt, dass das Mikrofon aus war.
Du musst ein bisschen vorsichtiger reden, sonst bricht es wieder ab.
Ich versuche nicht so laut zu schreien.
Ja.
Wo ich...
Okay, ganz vorsichtig.
So.
Wir versuchen es noch einmal. Ja. Gerade ist der Podcast mehrere Mal unterbrochen worden von einem, wir wissen nicht genau, wir können den technischen Grund nicht genau einordnen. Wir versuchen jetzt einfach ein bisschen vorsichtiger Witze zu machen. Okay, nicht so edgy. Bewegt dich nicht mehr. Ja, ich habe dir gerade gesagt, dieser Witz war vielleicht ein bisschen zu edgy. Ja, war ein bisschen. Das kannst du in deiner WhatsApp-Gruppe machen, aber nicht hier. Genau, bei WhatsApp-Gruppen waren wir stehen geblieben. Richtig. Denn ich war ja letzte Woche bei Daniel Sloss. Daniel Sloss! Ja, psch! Unser gemeinsamer Freund aus Schottland, den unsere Agentur nach Deutschland geholt hat. Und der hat wirklich ein fantastisches Stand-up hier in Köln gemacht. Der Ort war ein bisschen weird, es war eine Kirche, es war die Kulturkirche. Und es ist ja nicht so wirklich, also es ist schon derber Humor und das war schon irgendwie ein spannender Kontrast in der Kirche, in dem Haus Gottes, wie ich ja immer sage, zu Kirchen. Schon der da hat eine Witze gemacht, das war toll, ganz toller Act, also mega gut geschrieben, super tiefgründig und auch sehr monothematisch, also jedes Thema baut aufeinander auf, am Ende fasst er alles nochmal zusammen, das hat einen Grund, warum er diese ganzen Themen anspricht, das war wirklich ganz toll, sehr zeitgemäß, aber nicht mit dem erhobenen Zeigefinger, sondern auch wirklich einfach sehr, sehr lustig. Cool. So viel Spaß gemacht. Er hat auch über eine WhatsApp-Gruppe gesprochen, die er mit sehr vielen Comedians hat. Die schlimmste Form der WhatsApp-Gruppe eigentlich, glaube ich sogar, wo sich jeder meint, übertrumpfen zu müssen und dann ein Comedian geschrieben hat, oh, ja, mein Hund ist heute gestorben und daraufhin die Hölle ausgebrochen ist in dieser Gruppe, wo alle darüber witzig gemacht haben und so. Es ging auch viel um den Umgang mit Humor und Trauerbewältigung etc. und dass Humor doch ein gutes Mittel dafür ist.
Aber es wird halt dazu geneigt, dass man Humor hat, man verteufelt nach furchtbaren Situationen, aber das ist ja vieler Quatsch, das ist ein guter Umgang damit. Auf jeden Fall. In der Meinung sind wir auch schon länger. Zwei Specials auf Netflix kann man sich auf jeden Fall angucken. Die beide auch das Thema haben im Prinzip, auch sehr ernst werden daraus. Ja, total, seine Schwester ist ja gestorben und das behandelt er. Und das war auf jeden Fall sehr interessant. Grossartig, schaut es euch an. Auf jeden Fall toller Stand-Up, mega modern zeitgemäß. Also das ist irgendwie cooler, moderner Stand-Up. Irgendwie gefühlt kommen da neue Comedians gerade an den Start, die immer neue Ebenen reinbringen und so. Das ist toll anzugucken. Cool. Vielleicht kommt er nochmal nach Deutschland. Er hat mir nett geschrieben und würde gerne mal abends mit uns beiden was unternehmen. Wirklich? Das hat nicht funktioniert jetzt, aber vielleicht machen wir das noch. Das stimmt, ja. Ja, wir schauen mal. Vielleicht kriegen wir ihn in den Podcast eingeladen. Dann müssen wir Schottisch lernen, dann müssen wir alle hier im Fake-Schottischen Akzent. Schottisch. Schottisch. Mein Fondue am Wochenende, danke der Nachfrage, war ein grosser, laufen wir noch eigentlich? Vor allem, wirklich, wir haben das grosse Planetengewinnspiel gemacht. Nehmt uns einen Planeten und ihr kriegt einen Ausflug ins Planetarium. Eine Mail. Wir haben das grosse Hip-Hop-Gewinnspiel gemacht, ja, schreibt uns irgendwie 16 Lines und wir organisieren euch ein... Wir schicken euch das Genre Hip-Hop. Ja, und ein Treffen mit. Eine Mail. Das grosse Milch-Gewinnspiel. Schickt uns irgendeinen coolen Reim auf Milch und ihr gewinnt einen Ausflug zu weinen Stefan. Null Mails. Du erwähnst nebenbei, dass du ein Käse von Du planst. 120 Mails! Deswegen kam ich auch nur drauf, weil ich es hier gerade schon wieder in der Twitter-Timeline aufploppen sehe. Leute, das ist ein Trigger-Word, also ein positives Trigger-Word. Ja, die Leute lieben Fondues. Die Leute lieben Fondues. Ist Fondue die beste Idee aller Zeiten? Und jeder, dachte ich auch, bis dann bis zum Fondue. Und jeder hat aber irgendwie auch so ein Rezept in der Tasche und ist immer das gleiche. Ja, das kann man auch immer allen sagen. Also ich habe sehr viele Rezepte von euch bekommen, es war exakt das gleiche, immer. Also, ich habe hier im Kölner Käsehaus bestellt, Vacherin Fribourgeois 50%, 50% Grier. Das ist, dachte ich, wow, ich habe das Rezept bekommen von einem Schweizer Koch, muss man dazu sagen, so, deswegen dachte ich mir, wow, du bist ja ganz speziell, ich wollte auch so ein spezielles Schweizer Familienrezept eigentlich haben, also so eine Handgesch, wo man am Zettel noch die Jahre ansieht. Wo man den Zettel kann aufschreiben und so kannst du die Jahresringe zählen, tausend. So ein Rezept wollte ich haben. Nein, ich habe von einem Schweizer Koch da ein Rezept bekommen, war genauso stolz, stellt sich raus, das ist standardmässige Fondue. So, das ist einfach das, und dann habe ich das der Käsefrau gesagt, dachte so, haben Sie das denn da? Und sie so, ja, ja. Hier, die Fondue-Mischung, dann haben Sie so eine Schaufel einfach direkt von der Füße. Ja, haben wir schon, haben wir jetzt fertig, können Sie jetzt abholen. Und hat mir aber noch geraten, noch ein bisschen Emmentaler dazu zu packen, damit es halt schön Fäden zieht. Aha. Weil das ist der, Emmentaler ist nämlich der Aspekt, der die Fäden zum. Ah, der ist für die Fäden da. So, war die grosse Frage, will man die Fäden, will man die Fäden, ja nein. Und ich dachte mir, ja, oder? Von die gehören auch Fäden, man hat Spaß mit Fäden. Rausziehen und dann so einwickeln, einwickeln, ein bisschen Spaghetti. Haben mir die grossen Spaß vorgestellt, also noch ein bisschen Emmentaler rein. So, ich dachte ja prinzipiell, ich habe auch jetzt nur einen Schweizer Kollegen und so, daher kam auch ein bisschen die Idee und den habe ich ja gelobt. Seit Jahren lobe ich den dafür, wie toll das ist, dass die Schweizer den Käse in den Mittelpunkt stellen.
Du hast ja dazu nur Brot.
Ja.
So, Brot, aber auch geschmackloses Weissbrot im Prinzip.
Einfach nur, um ein bisschen diese Kultröder zu haben.
Eine lebende Schaufel, einfach eine essbare Schaufel.
Eine lebende Schaufel.
Eine essbare Schaufel.
Jetzt die Armen, alle Vegetarier haben sich kurz erschreckt. Oh, wie lebt ein Zwiebelboden lebt? Genau. Aber es ist halt toll, weil ich glaube, es ist nur dafür da, dass die Kohlenhydrate das Fett bündeln im Körper und so, dass man es irgendwie aufnehmen kann einigermaßen. Und ich fand es toll, weil der Käse steht so doll im Mittelpunkt, wie es nicht anders geht. Nein, denn die Grundlage von Käsefondue ist Wein. Du machst so viel Wein da rein, in diesen Topf, dann kommt noch ein bisschen Zitronensaft rein, Muskat, Pfeffer, Maisstärke, deine Gruyere, Fribourgeois, Bullshit, Nettomischung kommt da dann rein und dann kocht es halt so ein. Aber was bleibt am Ende über? Der Alkoholgeschmack. Ich war sehr enttäuscht. Du hast nur Wein geschmeckt? Man hat schon auch Käse geschmeckt, aber auch schon auch sehr viel Wein, ehrlich gesagt. Nun kommt ja noch Kirschwasser rein, Kirschschnaps, der gehört ja auch dazu. Ich, naivling, habe mir das vorgestellt, dass es dann so eine Kirschnote reinbringt. Nein, Alkohol primär einfach. Das war, es ist schon lecker gewesen, aber für mich war das, ich habe die Schweizer durchschaut gefühlt. Nicht der Käse steht in den Mittelpunkt, sondern der Alkohol steht in den Mittelpunkt. Und weil die halt Käse rumliegen haben, haben die überlegt, wie können wir Alkohol noch konsumieren, ja, ach so mit Käse. Aber wie kam es an? Kam es gut an oder war es ein Debakel und alle Lagen betrunken? Nee, nee, nee, nee, da habe ich für meine Familie gemacht, es kam sehr gut an. Ja, es waren Debakel, alle waren am Ende besoffen, ist ja auch das, was man mit einem Familienfestival des Tages erzielen möchte. Nee, es kam bei allen sehr gut an, ich war als Koch der Einzige, der enttäuscht war ein bisschen, weil ich habe mir das käsiger vorgestellt. So ist es ja oft, du stehst den ganzen Tag in der Küche und am Ende kannst du genauso gut irgendwie so einen Schnaps. Ja, ich einfach Schnaps auszeigen kann, ja, aber kaufen kann, Arbeit sparen kann. Nee, ist ja sehr schnell zu machen, das ist ja auch wirklich kein aufwendiges Gericht. Und dann schön unten angebrannt, noch ein bisschen krustig. Am Ende des Tages brennt es unten an. Geil. Das ist das Beste, dann nochmal die Kruste. Dann nennt man dann die Grossmutter, nennt man das dann wohl. Ja. Und man streitet sich um die Grossmutter. Sehr generell der Spaß, wer lässt ein Brot reinfallen, der muss ja dann eigentlich was bezahlen oder was im Körperteil aushebeln. Ja, ich habe die Regel nicht genau gelesen. Die Spielanleitung habe ich vorher weggeworfen, kennt man ja. Ja, genau, und das ist der große Spaß, auch wer darf am Ende die Grossmutter essen. Ja, aber ehrlich gesagt war sehr viel Fondue, da hat niemand mehr Lust auf die Grossmutter gehabt. Legt man jetzt die Grossmutter weg ins Bett. Und dann immer der demütigende Gang zur Mülltonne, wo man dann noch irgendwie so einen Klassikbeutel-Käse einfach wegwirft. Einfach den schönen Grand-Hois-Vosemmire, dann einfach schön weg und jetzt Stadtkatzen freuen sich. Ne, das war interessant, interessante Erfahrung. Ich bin dabei, jetzt neue Gerichte auszuprobieren. Koch-Stefan ist zurück. Freut mich. Ja, freut mich. Ist aber schwer für einen eine Person zu machen, oder so ein Fondue, dann einfach so eine Tasse in die Mikrowelle oder so. Du kannst immer, du musst immer einen Riesen-Act machen. Es ist ein Riesen-Act gewesen, deswegen war gut, wenn Leute kommen, mache ich da gerne auch einen Act dann draus. Ich brauche dann die Challenge, weißt du, wenn Leute kommen, gerade Verwandte, dann ist es natürlich für mich immer interessant, diesen Abend so eine Challenge zu machen und zu überlegen, sich was Neues auszudenken. Mal schön austern. Ich bin jetzt bei YouTube in so einem Loch, so Handwerktipps und auch austern. Da war einer so, der zeigt, wie man austern richtig aufbricht und so. Und total abgefahren und es sieht total lecker aus. Wahrscheinlich ist es überhaupt nicht lecker, aber es sieht so ganz wenig, so wenn man viel arbeitet für wenig. Das sind wie diese Quadrat-Frucht-Gummi-Dinger, wo man ganz viel knibbeln muss, um dann irgendwie so diesen Hauch von Geschmack zu kriegen. Wo oft dann auch noch Papier an den Bonbon klebt, aber irgendwann an dem Punkt, dass man sagt, man fuck it, jetzt endlich das Papier auch mit. Man braucht genauso lange es zu essen, wie man Zeit braucht, um das nächste aufzumachen. Du bist konstant am Arbeiten. Stichwort, deswegen ist Pistazien das Beste. Genau, das ist das Ding. Pistazien sind glaube ich nicht so mega gesund auch, ist scheißegal. Jedenfalls, man isst nicht so viel, weil man sehr viel beschäftigt ist, damit zu knibbeln. Genau, und so stelle ich mir Ausland auch vor, so dass es dann so, dann hat der, die werden ja auf Salz serviert, damit die es umkippen. Genau, und du kriegst die ja schon gebrochen. Und grossartig. Du kriegst ja schon aufgeknipst. Das war ja meine Kann-Erfahrung.
Ausland in Kann.
Das war fantastisch. Jetzt an der Côte d'Azur
bist nominiert mit deiner Serie.
Das war wirklich der beste Moment.
War das das Highlight deines Lebens? Bislang glaube ich schon.
War das der beste Moment? Ich glaube schon.
Und dann kriegst du, haben wir Ausland gegessen
und uns haben so ein riesen Schiff,
also wirklich die Form eines Schiffes
wurde so eine, ja, wie so eine Schüssel, also also haben eine Form eines Schiffes auf unseren Tisch gestellt und auf Eis und Salz serviert aus dann gegessen. Die haben dann oft noch so Beeren drin teilweise oder so, teilweise waren die Rohr. Die sind aber schon geknipst. Welche Beeren? So Cassis. In den Austern dann mit drin? Schon, auch dann reingemacht. Aber du denkst gerade, man macht die noch auf. Ja, ne, ne. Die machst du, wenn du frisch auf dem Watt unterwegs bist, dann kannst du die aufmachen. Das Wecksnacken einfach. Bestimmt schon, es ist halt so ein Problem von Tieren. Die leben ja auch noch, du schneidest die ja durch, dann schlifft sie die. Das ist schon ein bisschen abgefahren, aber wo man denkt so, was ist Leben eigentlich dann, wenn so ein Schleimding... Das fragt man sich die ganze Zeit bei Auslandessen, was ist Leben eigentlich. Es ist auch automatisch, man rät über Fussballergebnisse und so und dann werden die Ausland auf den Tisch gestellt, man beginnt zu essen und direkt switcht das Thema zu, was ist das Leben. Was heißt das eigentlich, Leben? Wann endet es eigentlich? Ja, wann fängt es an, wann hört es auf? Ja, wenn du da so ein hingehortztes Schleimteil hast, wo du auch denkst, was ist da genau vorne und hinten?
Aber das ist halt so das Problem, manche Tiere eignen sich halt einfach gut zum Essen.
Das ist natürlich schade für die, ist natürlich unglücklich, weil die dann halt gegessen werden.
Aber kein Tier ist so gut servierbar wie die Auster.
Deswegen, du hast diesen schönen, schimmernden, glänzenden Unterbau gut in der Hand, wo du denkst, wenn du auch schon auf einem Teller geboren wirst als Auster, wo du denkst, oh, oh, oh, oh, was ist das für eine rote Beere hier neben mir? Scheiße. Ja, so ein Strohalm drin fehlt noch oder so eine Gabel, die schon dabeigelegt ist. Bekennt man ja, wenn man so bestimmte Joghurts aufmacht, so hat man oben schon diesen Plastiklöffel drin. Ich finde es ja gut, wenn Austern irgendwann alle mit so einem Plastiklöffel oder so schon in diesem Papier eingeschweißt, obendran geboren werden, die auch immer dann what the fuck, Leute. Und die Auster in der Tiere WhatsApp-Gruppe, ey Leute, kann es sein, dass ich gegessen werde und das Schwein nur so, alle, nein und der Eisbär so, Leute, ich habe ganz andere Probleme. Ja, ganz andere Probleme, hier schmilzt gerade weg, holy shit, Feuer, Flammen, Emoji, Emoji, Emoji. Oder die Schlange so, von mir hat man Angst, mich isst niemand. Manche essen dich auch Schlange. Ja, manche essen dich auch, schön geröstet, mhm, schöne Schlangefleisch. Das ist auch ein merkwürdiges Tier, weiß man auch nicht, wo vorne und hinten ist. Man weiß auch nicht, wie es sich fortbewegt, bis heute ja nicht. Weiss kein Mensch. Muskeln sagen die einen, Mini-Beinchen sagen die anderen. Ja, oder wenn niemand hinguckt, stehen die auf und laufen so kurz zu Stück, bis niemand mehr hinschaut. Weiss auch, au, apropos, du fragst dich wahrscheinlich, mein Gott, warum bin ich heute zu spät gekommen? Ja, ich hatte ein paar Minütchen Verspätung, bin ich sehr ehrlich dazu. Grund dafür, ich wurde beschattet. Du wurdest beschattet? Ich wurde beschattet. Ich habe mich heute ins Auto gesetzt, schön Car to go gemietet, schön weggesnackt. Und dann setze ich mich rein und neben mir ist so ein Handwerkerauto, guckt mich so an und dann in dem Moment, in dem sich unsere Blicke treffen, hat er sich so in den Sitz reingedrückt. So richtig so dieses, ich will nicht gesehen werden. Ja, problematisch, wenn ich schon Augenkontakt hatte. Aber was soll man machen? Ist es so dieses Problem, du wirst während dem Schleichen erfasst und dann einfach einfrieren? Das bin ich in Oceans 12, glaube ich, nee, 13, den besten Trick eigentlich. Sei lustig, aber nicht zu lustig, sei höflich, aber so sehr, ach so, dass ich das nicht merken kann, diese Mediocracy, wie man einen Tag legen muss. Eigentlich müssen wir kurz überlegen. Und das Allerwichtigste, tu auf gar keinen Fall Rusty, ja, okay. Stimmt. Viele Gags gehen da manchmal unter, aber es ist schon... Stimmt, das war die Punchline sogar, das Witz, oder? Aber das ist, weil ich das immer noch, denke ich da gerne dran zurück. Ja, es ist gut, sei lustig, aber bringe ihn nicht zum Lachen. Bring ihn nicht zum Lachen, genau. Sei höflich, aber nicht so nett, dass er sich nicht merkt. Und das hat der Handwerker ihm überhaupt nicht beachtet. So wurde er einfach direkt, und ich dachte mir, okay, komisch, und dann bin ich losgefahren, und dann fährt man so ein Stück los, und dann so dieses Scheinwerfergehen an bei ihm, er fährt auch los. Da dachte ich mir, Moment mal, was ist das denn jetzt hier? Was, also, versuchte jemand den geheimen Ort unserer Podcastaufnahme rauszufinden? Ist es einer von deinen Freunden, die sich ärgern, dass du ihn immer absagst? Was ist da los? Mal gucken, ob die heute morgen auch aufnehmen. Ja, und dann fahre ich so rum, biegt nach rechts ab, biegt auch nach rechts ab, direkt hinter mir, Ampel, hinter mir, gucke ich mal links ab, links ab, biege auch links ab. Warst du dich dann verfahren oder bist du noch? Ich habe mich massiv verfahren, direkt in McDrive rein. Er auch in McDrive rein, er war noch nervöser. Ich habe mir einen Fish Mac geholt, er hat sich auch einen Fish Mac geholt. Beide keinen Geschmack, ihr habt beide keinen Geschmack. Ich habe keinen Tränkel gegeben. Er hat auch keinen Tränkel gegeben. Ist es der Mann, der gerade neben mir sitzt eigentlich? Ja, Heinz, komm mal, nimm dir ein Mikrofon. Und dann dachte ich mir wirklich so, jetzt muss ich den abschütteln. Weil natürlich, ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen so das Ding, dadurch, dass man so durch Unterhaltung aufgedrillt wird, dass gefährliche Situationen unterhaltsame Situationen sind durch Filme. Hat man direkt Spaß. Deswegen freue ich mich ja auch auf Zombie-Apokalyptien. Ja, genau. Wahrscheinlich, ich denke auch so, wenn in so einer dunklen Gasse jemand ein Messer zieht, ich denke mir, ah, geil! Ich würde aber ganz gerne einen Zombiefilm machen, wo sich die Leute im Film Zombiefilme kennen und eigentlich primär Lust darauf haben. Ja, Zombieland.
Ist Zombieland, ne? Ich habe Zombieland nie gesehen, das ist das Problem.
Aber ich kriege immer sehr schlechte Reaktionen.
Ich finde es immer lustig, wenn jemand eine Idee äussert und man einfach sagt, also exakt so wie das Buch.
Ja, genau. Ich kriege auch immer nicht so gute Reaktionen auf diesen Pitch, aber ist mir egal, ich mag es gern.
Und deswegen dachten wir schon, dass es vielleicht das gibt. Aber okay.
Ist es nicht sogar bei The Walking Dead auch so?
Ja, jetzt ist gut.
Are we gonna say the word? Are we gonna say the Z-word?
Are we gonna say it or is it just me?
Zoe?
No, like The Walking Dead, Coming Out of Grey.
Nein, nein, like a...
Beisser heisst die doch. Beisser, sagen die.
Was meinst du?
Like...
Zombie.
Like a zombie. What? Aber die sagen es nie Zombie. Nee, aber das eine Kind hat so ein Comicbuch, so Rise of the Zombies, und fragt so, warum haben wir die Beisser genannt? Wichtig Beisser? Wer findet so einen Namen? Ja, der erste Lokalreporter, der dann irgendwie einen halbgaren... Beisser-Gate. Beisser-Gate. Auf jeden Fall, ich bin weitergefahren und ich war so direkt im, ne, es geht so richtig die Donald Duck-Musik an, also die coole, die Darkwing Duck-Musik. Ja. Die Darkwing Duck-Musik geht an in meinem Kopf. Mir werden jetzt andere Moods eingefallen, aber gut. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
In deinem Leben läuft auch die ganze Zeit Baby-Elephant-War in deinem Kopf.
Ja, konstant.
Und dann dachte ich mir, den muss jetzt abschütteln.
Und dann dachte ich mir, wie macht man das?
Ist das so Schlangenlinien fahren?
Im Cut-to-Go frage ich mich auch wie.
Weil das bleibt maximal 80.
Naja, aber es ist eigentlich perfekt, weil du hast ganz viel, das ist so ein bisschen wie am Anfang von Dark Knight,
wo die Einbrecher, die Clown-Einbrecher dann mit einem Schulbus rausfahren und in diese ganz lange Reihe von Schulbussen reinfahren und du natürlich als Polizei keine Chance mehr hast, weil die halt genau morgens zur Schulbuszeit. Wo ich mir auch immer gefragt habe, dass da niemand mal sagt, von diesen Schulbusfahrern dann da, Leute, der ist vorbegratet. Ihr glaubt nicht, was ich heute gesehen habe. Der ist aus der Bank rausgebrochen. In diese eine Lücke, die ich gelassen habe, weil ich voll zwei mein Handy abfallen lassen im Fußraum. Obwohl man auch nicht weiß, sind es Komplizen? Ja, ja, genau. Das ist immer die Sache bei dem Christopher-Nolan-Film. Ist es auch Teil des... Ne, ja, aber unabhängig von Verschwörungstheorien, aber es will uns der Film mitteilen, wow, die haben das so gut geplant, dass die selber die gekapert haben, die Schulbusse? Ich glaube schon. Woher kriegt man Schulbus eigentlich? Da kommt dann so ein Typ mit so einer Clowns-Massel und sagt, hallo, brauchen Sie Ihre Busse noch? Ja, jeden Tag. Das Weirdeste, wir arbeiten in der Nähe von einem DHL-Packzentrum, wo halt Millionen von diesen DHL-Autos stehen. Und die fahren dann morgens in die Welt. Das erinnert mich immer an The Dark Knight. Ja, vor allem diese Stationen, diese Belader-Stationen und dann fahren die, dann scheren die alle so aus. Das ist echt cool. Ja, und alle fahren in andere Richtungen, alle fahren vom Hof. Wenn du Pech hast, kommst du dann an einen Zeitpunkt an, wo du dann nicht mehr wegkommst. Die Gelbe Welle, sag ich manchmal. Wo sagst du manchmal. Ja, präge ich jetzt einfach den Begriff. Sagst du laut dann oder was? Oder sagst du das zu dir? Hashtag die Gelbe Welle. Wo stehst du dann da so und sagst dann, ah die gelbe Welle. Ich versuche immer so kultbegriffe. Du bist ja allein zur Arbeit. Wann sagst du die gelbe Welle? Ich sag das laut. Du stehst dann da und dann fanden die raus und du sagst dir das und dann, rufst du das oder wie sagst du? Nee, sag ich, boah die gelbe Welle. Und du hörst einfach das Kopfhör auch auf, ne? Ja klar. Machst du die Musik dafür aus? Nein. Die Musik ballert weiter. Naja, ich mach die Lüftung aus. Also heute Morgen war die Lüftung laut, weil ich wollte es warm haben. Ich mach schon die Lüftung aus und dann so die gelbe Welle. Guckst du dich denn um, ob es jemand gehört hat? Ja, ich dachte schon so ein bisschen, ob was zurückkommt, aber oft kommt nicht zurück. Aber ich würde halt gerne so einen Kultbegriff prägen, so wirklich, wo man sagt, oh, keine Ahnung, irgendwie so Herrengedeck oder sowas, so Kultbegriffe. Ja. Ist mir noch nicht gelungen. Smisma geht unter, die Google-Suchergebnisse für Smisma fallen steil ab. Unser Podcast ist der lebende Beweis dafür, dass wir nicht bereit sind, wir können keinen Kult kreieren. Das funktioniert einfach nicht. So, aber ich bin ganz gespannt, wie diese Geschichte weitergeht. Ich wollte ihn abschütteln. Du kannst ihn abschütteln, du kannst das Karte nur wechseln können. Nee, vor allem, ich hatte dieses Wort im Kopf, abschütteln.
Und man denkt, dann schreibt man halt so, keine Ahnung, würde man sich schreiben, ja, er schüttelt den ab. Aber wie genau das aussieht, weiß ich auch nicht genau. Und dann dachte ich mir, ich mach den Klassiker, weil ich hab mir nur gehört, wenn er jemanden verfolgt, zu Fuß. Hey Siri, wie schüttelt man niemanden ab? Ja genau, oder so Boardcomputer, abschütteln. Immer so hin und her. Und ich habe nur gehört, wenn ein zu Fuß jemanden verfolgt, soll man halt dann einfach die Richtung ändern und dem entgegenlaufen und dann gucken, ob er auch die Richtung ändert und dann sagt, hallo! Messer in den Bauch gestopft. Ja, ist schwierig. Ich habe einfach die klassische Variante viermal links gemacht. Du bist viermal links ab. Oder im Kreisverkehr auch geil, einfach so lange zu fahren. Ja, stimmt, ja. Und dann irgendwann ist der Kreisverkehr einfach voller Leute, die sich alle folgen und die gesamte Stadt ist verstanden. Kommt nicht mehr raus, ja. Und ich dachte mir viermal links abbiegen, weil dann bist du ja wieder gerade und der wird dir wahrscheinlich nicht folgen, weil das ist ja kein sinnvoller Weg. Und dann tatsächlich bin ich zweimal links abgebogen und dann ist er weg. Okay, das heißt, du weißt aber bis heute nicht. Das war ein Handwerkerauto, ich weiß nicht genau, welche Art von Handwerk, könnte Malerei gewesen sein. Doch, ich glaube nämlich. Tischlerei, Fensteraustausch, Kranbau, Heizungsbau, Heizungseinbau, Sanierung im beidesten Sinne, die den Boden machen, die Wände machen, Türen, könnte alles gewesen sein, Tür auf, Tür zu, weiß man nicht genau. Die Türen auf und zu machen. Ich habe ihn auf jeden Fall erfolgreich abgeschüttelt, bin aber ein bisschen zu spät gekommen. Ich weiß nicht, wie es jetzt aussieht, wenn ich jetzt wieder hier wegfahre. Dann steht es wahrscheinlich auf dem Hof. Wahrscheinlich. Was macht man dann? Abspann kommt dann aber auch, man braucht keine Angst haben. Also bevor irgendwas passiert, kommt der Abspann. Ja, das stimmt. Der Cliffhanger ist zu gut. Der Cliffhanger, ja. Ich warte immer auf den Cliffhanger. Warte auf den Cliffhanger. Mal einfach mit den Leuten reden, einfach mal sagen so, Tim, beschatten Sie mich? Ja, ich glaube, meine These wäre, während du im Auto warst, sind zu Hause Leute bei dir eingebrochen. Ja. Und er ist dir gefolgt, um sicherzustellen, dass du nicht zu Hause bist. Aber woher wissen die, wo ich wohne? Die haben mich dann schon von Anfang an... Die beobachten dich schon länger. Länger? Ja, ja. Mindestens ein paar Tage, um deine Routinen zu checken. Ich habe jetzt einen Kontakt zu einer Polizistin, die uns geschrieben hat, wie man sich verhalten soll. Du hast Kontakt zu der. Auf Instagram. Und dann ist die Frage, und dachte ich mir immer mit auch, soll ich die jetzt anschreiben, so, hey, hier verfolgt mich einer. Ja. Ist das alleine schon illegal? Weiß ich nicht genau. Ja, ab wie viel Begungen ist illegal? Du kannst ja zufällig einen gleichen Weg haben. Ja, aber es gibt ja Stalking-Gesetze, man darf jemanden ja nicht stalken. Gilt das auch für Autofahrer oder für Reiter im Straßenverkehr? Wie weit ist das? Fahrradfahrer, die fahren hier hinterher und dann so, äh, langsamer, ich komme nicht hinterher. Das ist die schlechteste Idee aller Zeiten. Ja, interessant. Ich bin gespannt, wie diese Geschichte weitergeht. Ich mache ein bisschen Sorgen um dich auch. Ja, irgendwie ist das komisch, weil man sieht das immer so oft. Du bist ja eine Person des öffentlichen Lebens auch. Da kommt das schon mal vor, dass man verfolgt wird. Ich habe auch mal gesehen, dass ich an einem Auto vorbeigelaufen bin. Und da saß jemand drin. Und auch als er mich gesehen hat, hat er sich so geduckt. Wann war das? Das war gestern. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich Paronid bin. Ich bin nicht Paronid, aber irgendwie denke ich mir schon so, weird. Ja, weird. Dann läufst du weiter und sagst, die gelbe Welle. Werbung Weißt du, was das Problem ist? Mir schenkt niemand einfach so Geld. Ja? Ich muss so viel arbeiten immer und dann will ich bezahlen, okay, aber ich würde gerne
mal Geld geschenkt bekommen.
Ja, das ist doch ganz einfach.
Du musst einfach ein kostenloses Girokonto bei der Commerzbank aufmachen, dann kriegst
du 100 Euro Startgut haben obendrauf und wenn du es sogar an Freund und Familie weiterempfielst
und dir auch ein Konto machen, kriegst du noch mal 100 Euro obendrauf und du machst
nichts.
Die Commerzbank schenkt mir hunderte von Euros?
Ja, die sind so doof, die schenken ihr ihr ganzes Geld.
Warum tun sie das? Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber das ist eine Gelegenheit, die solltet ihr euch nicht entgehen lassen. Okay, wie schaffe ich das? Ja, du gehst einfach auf ufo.commerzbank.de und schaust dir an, wie du dein Konto erstellst, bei komplett digitaler Nutzung, kostenlos. Dauert das lange das Konto zu erstellen? Das dauert mehrere Jahre, ja, das ist leider das einzige Problem, dass es... Nein, das geht ganz schnell, einfach in wenigen Minuten hast du direkt dein Konto eröffnet. Du kannst loslegen und überweisen und das Beste habe ich ja noch gar nicht erwähnt, du kriegst eine eigene Kreditkarte obendrauf.
Meine eigene Kreditkarte? Cool, das freut mich sehr, das klingt nach dem, was ich brauche.
Das ist doch schön, wunderbar und jetzt ganz viel Spaß weiterhin mit dem Podcast.
Werbung
Ey, ich war in Berlin so erbärmlich. Ich glaube, das erbärmlichste Bild, das man haben kann. Und zwar, ich habe mir Essen
und dann geht es um die Werbung Ich hätte kein Zuhause. Und dann habe ich mein Auto einfach irgendwo geparkt, in so einer Reihe von Autos und habe im Auto das Essen gegessen. Und du hast dann quasi für deinen Essensplatz auch bezahlt, weil du hast ja wahrscheinlich Cardo-Go gehabt. Ja, das stimmt, genau. Dass du bezahlst für deinen Essensplatz, lieber als dass du kostenlos im Restaurant online sitzt. Was für Leute machen. Und vor allem dann, das Essen war ja warm und anscheinend so warm, dass das gesamte Auto beschlagen ist. Das heisst, was man von außen gesehen hat. Normales Auto, normales Auto, komplett beschlagenes Auto. Beschlagenes Auto, wo man durch noch Schlitze sehen kann, wie irgendjemand sich so umhüllt von Alufolien, so einen schönen Take-away reinwämst einfach und sich einfach denkt, wow, was ist da los, was ist da passiert. Ja, car to go, car to go, milchiges car to go, car to go, car to go. In Berlin kannst du ja nicht mal irgendwie schnell irgendwie in so ein Waldstück fahren, wo du deine Ruhe hast. Nee, du bist doch mitten in der Stadt. Das ist auch gut, mit der Prämisse zu starten, ich esse nicht alleine im Restaurant, weil es so weird, aber das Ziel haben, in ein Waldstück, in ein verlassenes Waldstück zuück. Ich will halt meine Ruhe haben. Ich will meine Ruhe haben. Aber können wir kurz darüber reden, warum es für dich weird ist, in einem Restaurant alleine zu essen? Ja, weil es ist so... Wenn du irgendwo alleine in der Stadt bist, ist es doch nicht schlimm. Ja, die Frage ist, was macht man da? Weil wenn du zu zweit bist, dann unterhält man sich und schweigt sich an und unangenehm und so. Aber wenn du alleine bist... Auch unangenehm. Wenn ich alleine essen würde, würde ich keine Ahnung, Podcast hören nebenbei. Schön Lage der Nation irgendwie aufs Ohr und dabei schön die Frühlingsrollen schnabulieren. Kein Problem. Aber das ist gesellschaftlich nicht akzeptiert. Du kannst nicht in einem Restaurant mit den Noise-Cancelling-Headphones sitzen, alleine. Da würde ich mir einfach komisch vorkommen. So, und genau so zum Beispiel liest man was nebenbei. Ich würde gerne was nebenbei lesen, beim Essen. will irgendwie was machen beim Essen. Kannst du aber beim Buch, beim Restaurant ist nichts ungeblieben. Aber alleine kommt mir komisch vor. Und dann vor allem, es ist ja... Ja, mir auch, die Frage ist ja suggestiv, aber trotzdem ist es doch Quatsch eigentlich. Ja, ich frage mich immer so, wohin mit meinen Augen, glaube ich, frage ich mich immer. Wohin mit meinen Augen, wohin mit meinen Händen, wohin mit meinen Augen? Wohin, genau, das ist so, wohin mit den Händen, klar beim Essen, irgendwie Messergabel,
das ist was du tun, das ist zumindest gut.
Und wohin mit den Augen, was guckt man an, guckt man die ganze Zeit sein Essen an, was macht man, während man kaut?
Ich glaube, ich bin es auch schon so gewohnt, während dem Essen am Rechner zu sitzen und was zu schauen,
dass ich gar nicht mehr weiß, wohin mit mir, so gucke ich das Restaurant,
und dann guckt man sich das Restaurant, aha, aha, aha, aber irgendwann hat man es dann auch gesehen und dann ist es so dann sind die augen verloren deswegen schön podcast an schön das ist eigentlich glaube ich so ein schönes bild für mein privat wobei lustigerweise podcast auch nichts für die augen tun aber ja genau man man hat man hat irgendwas zu tun gedanklich und ich glaube das ist genau ein gutes bild für mein Privatleben, ist in einem kondensierten Smart zu sitzen. Das ist für mich das Beste. Schön sich geschützt, man kann nicht rausgucken, perfekt. Die Augen können auch nichts tun. Können nichts tun. Weil die Scheiben beschlagen sind. Ich glaube, die Augen müssen nicht unbedingt was tun, aber sie müssen zumindest beschäftigt wirken. Ja, ich glaube, genau. Gibt denen was zu spielen, würde man mit dem Schauspieler auch sagen. Ja, genau. Aber tatsächlich verstehe ich beschlägene Scheiben bis heute nicht, genau. Ich glaube, ich habe es raus. Wenn mein Auto beschlägt von außen, bin ich immer verloren. Ich drücke auf sämtliche Knöpfe, diese Belüftungen von den Scheiben. Ich weiß nicht, ob ichärme machen muss im Auto, ob ich Kelle machen muss, ob die Temperatur überhaupt einen Einfluss hat. Mittlerweile bin ich gerade eher Standpunkt, Temperatur hat keinen Einfluss. Hauptsache Belüftung anmachen. Ich weiß echt nicht, was Scheiben funktionieren. Ich habe mich ja in meinen jungen Jahren intensiv mit Kondensstreifen auseinandergesetzt. Ah, okay. Ich habe mich ja mit der Verschwörungstheorie Chemtrails beschäftigt. Ja. Und damit man das versteht, muss man verstehen, wie Kondensstreifen funktionieren. Oder einfach kein Vollkirchen sein. Auch das. Einfach nicht tausend Euro für einen Chemtrailbuster ausgeben. Und dann habe ich mich mit Kondensation beschäftigt. Kondensation bedeutet, dass in der Luft zu viel Feuchtigkeit ist. Die Luft ist übersättigt an Feuchtigkeit. Sorry, ich stelle mal dumme Nachfragen. Aber jetzt sieht ja, jetzt kenne ich ja aber Kondenstropfen zum Beispiel, wenn ich mit einem heißen Teemacher oder sowas, ich kenne es ja aus der Werbung, da hast du diese Tröpfchen da am Glas. Aber beschlagene Scheiben sehen für mich ein bisschen anders aus. Und das heißt, es ist zu viel Feuchtigkeit in der Luft. Aber um zu kondensieren, was heißt zu viel Feuchtigkeit? Das hängt von der Temperatur der Luft ab, weil warme Luft kann mehr Feuchtigkeit aufnehmen als kalte Luft. Kennt man ja Tropen. Zum Beispiel das klassische Bild, wenn du in der Werbung darstellen willst, dass was kalt ist, eine kalte Cola-Flasche, dann hast du Kondensperlen dran. Warum? Weil kalte Luft keine, ich weiß nicht die Antwort, weil kalte Luft keine Feuchtigkeit aufnehmen kann. Genau, wenn die Luft sozusagen an die Flasche rankommt, kühlt die Luft sich ab und wird übersättigt, nicht weil sie feuchter wird, sondern weil sie kälter wird und mehr aufnehmen kann. Und dann braucht so Zeug noch etwas, woran es kondensieren kann. Einen sogenannten Kondensationskern. So, jetzt beschleckt die Flasche, daran kann es kondensieren. Genauso ist es auch, wenn es draußen kalt ist, dann ist die Scheibe ganz kalt, weil die Scheibe ist der Kontakt zur Außenwelt. Und ist die Scheibe kalt und die Luft, die an die Scheibe gerät, kühlt ab, wird übersättigt, kondensiert an der Scheibe. Aber jetzt steigt doch das Auto von innen. Das heißt, was du machen kannst, und ich glaube, jetzt kannst du zwei verschiedene Möglichkeiten wählen. Entweder du versuchst, die Feuchtigkeit im Auto zu reduzieren, was schwierig ist. Genau das zum Beispiel auch, wenn du viel atmest, wenn viele Leute sitzen sind dann ist es ganz feucht also entweder durch kälte oder die ist kann durch mehrere gründe übersättigt sein was man glaube ich versucht ist man versucht einfach die scheibe zu wärmen dass die scheibe nicht mehr so viel kälter ist als der rest so dass die luft nicht mehr übersättigt wenn sie an der scheibe ist ich glaube du versuchst, die Scheibe zu wärmen. Das ist es einfach.
Scheibe wärmen. Scheibe wärmen.
Oder Auto runterkühlen.
Aber wo soll dann die Feuchtigkeit hin? Die ist ja im Auto schon gefangen.
Ja, genau. Dann konnten sie jetzt überall.
Also ich habe auch nicht hundertprozentig
verstanden, aber ich glaube, was man
versucht, ist,
die Scheibe zu wärmen,
damit es nicht mehr zu stark abgekühlt wird an der Scheibe. Also warum geht die Feuchtigkeit zur kalten Scheibe? Weil die Scheibe kalt ist. Im Winter ist es draußen kalt. Ja, ja, warum geht die zur kalten Scheibe? Die ist halt da, Luft ist ja überall. Und die Luft, die an der Scheibe ist, wird gekühlt und wird dadurch übersättigt, weil die Luft eh schon feucht ist, weil ein Mensch drin ist in der Regel, dann atmest du ganz viel Feuchtigkeit aus.
Okay gut, das war sinnvoll. Also lass die Scheibe wärmen, schnell.
Lass uns schnell die Scheibe wärmen, so heisst ja auch der Knopf. Lass mich mal ganz kurz ran, die Scheibe wärmen.
Man ist irgendwann halt so dazu übergegangen, den Knöpfen im Auto diese immer gleichen Symbole zu geben, finde ich ja schwierig.
Ich würde gerne den Anti-Beschlagungsknopf anmachen, da kann es auch draufstehen. ABS. Ja. Nee, das gibt es auch schon bis jetzt. Aber halt so einen Knopf. Aber wir alle wissen, was am besten gegen Schlagen hilft, ist schön den Pullover über den Handballen stülpen und dann wild rubeln. Wild wedeln, Grünphase verpassenpassen, Mittelfinger bekommen schon, den dritten an dem Morgen. Schön sich so ein Fenster rubbeln und dann weiter. Also du für einen Fleck am Handballen haben. Immer am Handballen. Und dabei schön auf der Allee in den Baum rechts rein. Ja, immer schön handballen, ganz wichtig. Ja, ja, das funktioniert schon. Meine Morgenroutine ist mittlerweile, also mir ist etwas ganz Merkwürdiges passiert mir neuerdings. Es ist eine Metapher, ich weiß noch nicht genau wofür. Jeden Morgen komme ich mit der Bahn hier an und gehe in den immer gleichen Weg zur Firma. Immer gleichen Weg. Und jetzt neuerdings stolper ich jeden Morgen an der gleichen Stelle. Ja, es ist absurd mittlerweile. Also jeden Morgen stolper ich. Was ist das für eine Stelle? Und zwar ist es ein Gullideckel in der U-Bahn-Station. Der hat mich darauf aufmerksam gemacht. Ja, das ist so ein Deckel. Offensichtlich wurde der gewartet, wurde der rausgenommen, gewartet, was auch immer da drin ist. Die Turtles. Und wurde wieder drauf justiert, aber nicht so flach, ebenerdig wie davor, sondern steht ein bisschen hervor. Und jeden Morgen stolpere ich darüber, weil ich gehe offensichtlich... Wie läufst du mich den exakt gleichen Weg? Jeden Morgen, das ist mir erst mal aufgefallen, jeden Morgen gehe ich den exakt gleichen Weg, und unbewusst geht man den exakt gleichen Weg. Und auch mit den exakt gleichen Schritten wahrscheinlich. Ja, und jeden Morgen bleibe ich mit meinem rechten Fuß neuerdings an diesem Gullideckel hängen, oder was das ist, so eine Öffnung halt am Boden. So, und dann bleibe ich da halt jeden Morgen dann hängen, und ich habe mich bis zum ersten Mal fast hingeflogen, weil ich mit dem Affenzahn dagegen gelaufen bin, ich habe einen schnellen Schritt auch drauf. Ja, ja. Am zweiten Tag ging es dann einigermaßen, da muss ich aber schon lachen, weil es wieder der gleiche Tag war, der gleiche Stelle war. Und am dritten Mal musste ich dann einfach umgedreht wie James von, da heißt es doch James, von Dinner for One. Ach ja. Es ist nämlich exakt das gleiche, man stolpert auch genauso irgendwann Slapstick-artig wie bei diesem Tigerkopf und da guckt man sich auch so unbedingt, das kann nicht wahr sein. Und irgendwann machst du, davor bleibst du stehen und hüpfst so über die Gulli drüber. Ja, genau. Und dann beim vierten Mal musste ich wirklich einfach schallend loslachen und habe dann Leute gesehen, die mich gesehen haben, wie ich gestolpert bin, die zum ersten Mal gesehen haben, dass ich gestolpert bin und lachten und dachten, ich bin Joker-artig crazy. Und es ist ja so, in so einer U-Bahn-Station schallt es ja wirklich so. Ha ha ha! Schallt ich! Das musst du ausgesehen haben wie Joker. Gerade in der U-Bahn, ja. Gruseliger Mensch, der da plötzlich über den Gullideckel stolpert und dann lauslos lacht. Aber das ist wirklich sehr lustig. Ich glaube, es ist eine Metapher dafür, dass man in seinem Leben immer das Gleiche tun sollte, nichts ändern sollte. Weil sobald man etwa eine Kleinigkeit sich ändert in seinem Leben, wird es schlecht. Ja, oder wenn du nichts änderst, bist du zu anfällig für Störungen, wenn du immer das sehr machst. Aber interessant zu sehen. Ich fand es interessant zu sehen, dass man tatsächlich so sehr den gleichen Weg geht, also dass Routine... Aber das ist ja wahrscheinlich direkt nach einer Treppe, nehme ich mal an. Du gehst ja die Treppe runter. Treppe hoch. Ich komme von der Arbeit, ich komme von der Treppe hoch. Ja, und ich glaube, bei Treppen synchronisiert sich das ja, weil man wahrscheinlich immer mit demselben Fuss die Treppe beginnt und dann endet man auch mit demselben Fuss und ab dann ist es immer gleich. Also ich glaube nicht, dass ein gesamter Arbeitsweg gleich ist, sondern nur bei Treppen wieder zurückgesetzt wird. Aber ich bin auch sehr speziell bei Wegen, weil ich mir immer vorne nehme, den kürzesten Weg zu nehmen. Du bist ein verrücktes Huhn, Stefan. Ja, nee, nee, nee, also so extrem, dass ich wenige Zentimeter nur verschenken möchte, auch wenn ich um Ecken gehe und so weiter. Also auf so eine extreme Art, das meine ich. Kommt es aus deiner Formel-1-Phase vielleicht? OCD, ja, ich glaube schon. Dass du wirklich die Bestzeit schaffen willst? Ich gehe die Ideallinie. Und du machst auch Nee, aber das ist wirklich, ich bin so ein sehr... Zeit-Improvement ist wirklich das Nummer-eins-Ziel meines Lebens. Zeit ist das Wichtigste in meinen Augen. Und deswegen muss ich alles dafür tun, dass ich die Arbeitswege zum Beispiel auf Minimum reduziere. Und das geht so weit bei mir, da wird es dann verrückt. Dass du die dumme Gefährte bestellst, die dich dann lebensgefährliche Unfälle machen lassen. Genau, wo ich dann längere Zeit im Krankenhaus so bringe, als die ganze, ich verliere zu viel Zeit. Im Stau zu stehen, hat es glaube ich auch bei mir einen extremen Einfluss auf meinen Zustand. Du stehst nicht gerne im Stau. Sag mal Stefan, was höre ich denn hier für unglaubliche Wahlen? Aber Leute kommen damit klar, im Stau zu stehen, das meine ich. Bei mir dreht sich dann alles um, der Tag ist dann hinüber. Ja, das stimmt. Und das ist bei Wegen, habe ich wirklich versucht, ich glaube, mein Arbeitsweg ist so improved. Ich glaube, Leute können den gleichen Weg gehen wie ich, aber ich bin trotzdem irgendwie eine Minute schneller da, weil ich die Ecken schneide. Wollen wir mal ein Wettrennen machen? Wollen wir mal wirklich ein Geh-Wettrennen machen? Das kannst du ja nicht machen, weil du dann schneller gehst. Ja. Ich will auch nicht so viel Energie verbrennen. Vielleicht machen wir ein Wettrennen, ohne dass du es weißt. Genau. Vielleicht, genau, wir brauchen den Handwerker, wenn ich den sehe gleich, dann frage ich den, hey, wollen Sie Stefan Tietze beschatten? Und dann messen wir mal deinen Tag, wie schnell es ist, wie schnell du dich bewegst. Und dann können wir wirklich die Zeit messen. Vielleicht gibt es dann irgendein Muster. Dann bist du am Mittwoch ganz schnell und dann gegen Ende der Woche nimmt es wieder ab. Ich glaube, ich könnte Leuten Tipps geben, wie sie Zeit besser investieren. Also ich glaube, ich bin sehr gut darin, die Zwischensteps, zwischen den Tätigkeiten eines Tages auf ein Minimum zu reduzieren. Da bin ich mittlerweile sehr gut drin. Hast du da ein paar Tipps für unsere Hörer vielleicht? Nein, absolut. Du arbeitest an einem Buch. Ich arbeite an einem Buch und deswegen kann ich jetzt noch nicht spoilern. Dass du auf dreieinhalb Seiten runtergekürzt hast, damit du nicht zu viel Zeit zum Steilverbrauchst. Ja, das ist ja die Idee. Nee, aber sich immer bewusst zu machen, was mache ich gleich, was passiert auf dem Weg dahin und was muss ich noch tun und was kann ich auf dem Weg machen, wie kann ich den Weg bestmöglich nutzen?
Ich bin das exakte Gegenteil. Ich verbringe den Grossteil meiner Zeit. Du bist jetzt so verrückt. Du bist jetzt der verrückte Mensch. Nee, ich verbringe den Grossteil meiner Zeit zwischen Aktivitäten. Es ist immer so, wenn ich alleine zusammenrechnen würde, was ich an einem Tag so an Aktivitäten mache, 20 Minuten vielleicht, aber dazwischen immer stundenlang prokrastinieren und hin und her und immer noch ein Video und dann, ah, bevor ich das mache, muss ich ja noch das machen und jetzt habe ich noch eine Flasche im Kühlfach, die trinke ich erst, dann mache ich das, jetzt muss ich aber noch eine halbe Stunde warten, bis sie die richtige Temperatur hat, also kann ich jetzt eine halbe Stunde nichts machen, dann habe ich die Flasche.
Du bist halt der Meister selbst belügend.
Ja genau. Und dann ist es Nacht und ich denke mir, ja, es ist eh schon so spät. Ich versuche mich von einer Ausrede zur nächsten zu hangeln, um möglichst wenig zu machen.
Ich bestelle schon teilweise auf dem Weg nach Hause zu essen, mein Essen, damit ich, wenn ich ankomme zu Hause, das Essen kommt. Nee, das kenne ich nicht. Solche Sachen mache ich. Da kenne ich gar nichts. Du bist optimiert, du bist optimierter Stefan. Ja, time optimiert, zeitoptimiert, es ist glaube ich wirklich wichtig. Darum geht es doch eigentlich. Aber verpasst du da nicht das Leben? Nee, ich habe da Zeit fürs Leben. Manche würden sagen, zu viel Zeit. Wir haben auch Nachrichten bekommen zu dem Thema Netflix mit doppelter Geschwindigkeit und viele haben uns geschrieben, dass sie auch Podcasts regelmäßig mit doppelter oder zwei Komma, die haben ganz, ganz präzise Zahlen genannt. Ich habe auch 1,3 gehört. Ich habe 2,14 und 2,18 gehört. Also ich weiß nicht, was ihr für abgefahrene Podcast-Apps habt, dass ihr das auf die zweite Nachkommastelle. Ja, wirklich? Ja, weiß ich nicht. Was ist das ein Scherz? Bin ich geprankt worden? Kommt gleich jemand zur Tür rein? Ich bin auch erschrocken, wir haben euch gedreht und Podcast-Komparsen waren da. Vielen Dank an euch. Ihr wart da und seid zahlreich erschienen, mega cool. Das ist unfassbar toll. Das ist unfassbar toll. Dann habe ich kurz Hallo gesagt und die waren alle so unglaublich lustig. Ja, Moment, ich dachte ja, komm, an irgendeinem Punkt müssen wir auch mal einfach den Leuten das Feld überlassen. Ja, ja, wir müssen abgeben. Ich war ein bisschen stolz, man hat es weitergelehrt. Ja gut, aber die hören wahrscheinlich auch Gäste aus der Geisterbahnbahn so. Ja. Wir müssen irgendwann, wir geben eh irgendwann an die Telegram-Gruppe ab einfach. Ja gut, wir geben einfach ab. So, wir müssen das dann übernehmen einfach. Ja, ja. Aber da war ich, vielen Dank dafür fürs Kommen und vielen Dank für die lustigen Sachen. War das wieder eine Party-Tanzszene oder was? Nee, Schulszene. Schulszene? Ja. Okay. Ja, die Party-Tanzszene war aber auch, wo alle in letzter Staffel sehr skeptisch waren, dass meine Hörer, wie es immer hieß, in der Lage sind, eine Tanzszene aufzuführen, eine Clubszene, authentisch, weil es immer hieß, du hast doch so ein Nerdfans. Das war immer noch ein nachhaltiger Win, dass Top aussehende Menschen da ankamen, die alle fantastisch tanzen konnten und Cluberfahrungen haben. Aber passt, aber ich meine, so eine awkward Tanz, also so eine nicht hundertprozentig
selbstbewusste Tanzszene hätte ja auch gepasst, oder?
Ich meine, das ist ja, ist das nicht Rinseln auch in so einem Dorfclub?
Na klar.
Aber ja, wenn man was anderes erzählen will.
Will man halt so nicht sehen.
Auf der Kamera wird ja alles nochmal ein bisschen 20% cringier.
Ja?
Ist das so?
Ist das eine Regel?
Das ist ja mein zweites Buch, ja, wo ich dann über Schnitt und Serienoptimierung spreche. Apropos, du hast, natürlich ist viel passiert, auch in der Welt des Star Wars die letzte Woche. Richtig. Disney Plus ist gelauncht, grosse Probleme, ich habe es nicht hinbekommen, es anzuschauen. Ich habe es dir versucht zu erklären. Ich habe es auch verstanden, ich habe nur kein amerikanisches PayPal oder irgendwie sowas. Ich finde es bescheuert. Also Disney macht aber nicht alles falsch, Disney das Internet nicht verstanden, habe ich mich schon im anderen Podcast darüber aufgeregt, wie bescheuert das eigentlich ist, dass die das nicht gleichzeitig launchen. Was glauben die denn, erstmal werden alle Deutschen oder Europäer jetzt gespoilert, weil du konntest ja, wir benutzen ja alle ein Internet. Also was ist das für eine Vorstellung, dass man sich jetzt nicht, also wieso man sich im Internet verhalten, um nicht schon den großen ersten Spoiler zu hören, der ersten Folge. Aber auf der anderen Seite, die werden das wahrscheinlich nicht aus reiner Dummheit so machen, die werden wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Gründe haben, die wir nicht kennen. Ich habe die Gründe, aber es ist einfach wirklich. Ja, es ist ungünstig, aber die werden sich wahrscheinlich auch denken, ja, es ist scheiße, aber besser als die Alternative.
Das verstehe ich halt immer auch nicht. Es ist total bescheuert, vor allem es geht ja trotzdem irgendwie, du kannst ja im Internet nichts wirklich verbieten. Ich glaube, es ist eine rechte Schüssel, um ehrlich zu sein. Also man braucht erstmal einen VPN, um auf die Seite überhaupt zu kommen, weil wenn du über einen deutschen IP da raufgehst, dann kommt ja Launch da und da. Und dann braucht man noch einen ausländischen PayPal oder irgendwas Account oder Kreditkarte, weil die bei den Zahlungsdaten auch checken, wenn das eine deutsch stemmige Zahlungsart kommt. Genau, und es geht auch nicht jeder VPN. Da würde ich gerne mal den großen VPN-Test machen im Übrigen. Ich hatte mal CyberGhost, CyberGhost funktioniert nicht. Ich habe Hola. Okay, ich habe jetzt ExpressVPN, das funktioniert. Okay, und es klingt auch schnell, um ehrlich zu sein. Ich entscheide ja bei Apps, wo es dann viele Anbieter gibt, häufig nach dem Symbol. Das cleanste Symbol, was unten in meinem Dock und am besten aussieht, auf meinem Macbook, das nehme ich. Okay. Da bin ich, du nicht? Ich gehe nie nach Usability, ich gehe mal nach dem schönsten Logo. Ja, aber ich glaube, ich habe andere, also Hola ist ja so eine lächelnde Flamme, wo ich mir denke, ja, nehme ich. Klingt echt besser als, ExpressVPN ist so sehr funktional, gefällt mir nicht, um echt zu sein. Das habe ich dann auch nur genommen, weil das funktioniert, habe ich gelesen, dass es funktioniert. Genau, und dann konnte ich die erste Folge schauen, von The Mandalorian, der großen Star Wars Serie. Du willst nicht spoilern, weil man da nicht davon ausgehen kann, dass Leute das schon gesehen haben?
Mittlerweile sind auch schon, ich glaube, wieder neue zwei Folgen raus, die ich da nicht mehr geschaut habe, was auch was über die Serie aussagt.
Holy, holy shit.
15 Millionen Budget pro Folge haben die, 15 Millionen.
Oh, das ist ein unglaubliches Budget.
Und das ist wirklich, also auch John Farrow hat geschrieben, Dave Filoni, der Star Wars Rebels und Clone Wars vor allem in der Hand hatte, der hat das dann die erste Folge directed. Und das ist glaube ich das Problem, ehrlich gesagt, das ist gar nicht, das ist die ganz, ganz, ganz schlecht directed, ganz, ganz schlechte, schlechte Story, sehr faul alles, aber das Ende war halt irre. Aber da kann ich jetzt auch noch drauf warten, bis es dann in Deutschland rauskommt, alles. Das ist mir alles so anstrengend mit VPNs und so. Stefan! Ja, sorry. Ja, okay, nee, ist okay. Diese Stefanskritik-Ecke, du kannst hier machen, was du möchtest. Ich kann hier machen, was ich will. Es gibt andere, vor allem in der heutigen Zeit, wo es so viele tolle Serien gibt und so, man weiss ja gar nicht, was man alles gucken kann und man ist immer wahnsinnig befordert und ich neige mir immer dazu lieber, gar nichts zu gucken, weil einfach zu viel ist. Ich denke, ich sollte jetzt doch Mad Men zu Ende schauen, aber auf der anderen Seite gibt es auch andere coole neue Serien und so, dann macht man nichts aus der Angst, was zu verpassen. Lass sich da nicht, lass sich da nicht davon gängeln. Jetzt hat auch jemand geschrieben zu diesem Thema Beschleunigung, hat jemand gesagt, ja, Podcast höre ich irgendwie auf dreifache Geschwindigkeit und Serien halt nur so die mittelmässigen, die man gesehen haben muss, schaue ich auf doppelter Geschwindigkeit. Man muss auch denken, ja, wenn sie mittelmässig sind, dann schaue sie einfach nicht an und lasse sie nicht von irgendwie, das muss man gesehen haben, irgendwas sagen, aber gut, weiß es nicht. Was man auf jeden Fall auch gesehen haben muss, ist der fantastische Kontinent Afrika. Da hat alles angefangen,
die Wiege der Menschheit, wir alle sind Afrikaner
im Herzen, da kommen wir ursprünglich her.
Und vor zwei Wochen haben
wir unsere fantastische neue Rubrik Antenne Afrika
gestartet. Antenne Afrika, Arriba Afrika.
Ja, da brauchen wir euch auch noch ein
Intro, falls ihr Intro Ideen habt
für Antenne Afrika, schickt sie
uns auf jeden Fall. Nalt, Gonya, Ravim, Dibaba, Dibaba, Dibaba, Antenne Afrika. Aber das ist ja, das verbindet sich mit Afrika, aber wir haben ja gelernt, Afrika besteht aus 55 sehr unterschiedlichen, sehr individuellen Ländern. Und nicht nur König der Löwen. Wo gehört König der Löwen hin? Gute Frage. Also dieses klassische Savanne, Löwe, Giraffe, Afrika, wo ist das denn?
Kenia, keine Ahnung. Schickt uns mal von jedem Land so eine Vignette, so eine Impression, wie man sich das vorzustellen hat. Es ist wahrscheinlich auch schwierig, wie würde es bei Deutschland aussehen. Ja, schwierig.
Aber apropos Afrika, ich habe auch was beizusteuern, denn ich war mal wieder, es war in Köln, in Book of Mormon.
The Book of Mormon war in Köln, der London-Cast tourt gerade rum. Nächste Woche sind sie in Zürich, glaube ich. Lächste Woche waren sie in Köln und ich war mal wieder in Book of Mormon. Ein nach wie vor fantastisches Musical, leider war die Akustik in diesem Kölner Musical-Zelt echt grauenhaft. War nicht cool, also das war halt, gut wir haben es auch wirklich in New York gesehen, besser geht es dann auch glaube ich gar nicht, war die Karte auch noch ein bisschen cooler, aber was ein Fantastisch Musical, wo es auch um Afrika geht und wo es auch diesen grossartigen Song gibt, We Are Africa, wo halt diese acht whitest, the whitest of white boys singen We Are Africa, weil sie jetzt meinen Afrika cool zu finden und so, wo es ja auch ein bisschen um diese Stereotype geht und so, wo auch häufig sehr lustig gemacht wird, dass Afrika eben nicht nur König der Löwen ist, sondern vor allem ein vielseitiger Kontinent. Und wir haben jetzt eine neue Rubrik gestartet, wo ihr uns Beiträge schicken könnt aus euren jeweiligen Ländern, wo ihr gerade vielleicht zu Besuch seid oder wo ihr Verwandte habt. Wir hatten schon einen tollen Beitrag über Namibia, wo auch viel passiert ist, um ehrlich zu sein. Da haben wir jetzt sehr viele Nachrichten bekommen, dass die Strassennamen in Namibia geändert werden. Anscheinend haben wir da was angestossen, die kulturelle Revolution. Man sagt sich endlich los von dem Kolonialerbe der Deutschen. Gott sei Dank. Sehr gut, unterstützen wir auf jeden Fall. Und ja, deutsche Namen werden geändert. Jetzt ist natürlich so der Punkt, jetzt brauchen wir neue Namen. Also ich meine, die brauchen neue Namen. So der Punkt, wie nennt man die jetzt? Wir sind aber auch Afrika. Wir sind Afrika. Wir brauchen neue Namen. Ich meine, wenn, ich meine, Strassen benennen ist immer schwer. Selbst in Namibia, da gibt es die Hauptstrasse, da gibt es die Goethe-Strasse, da gibt es die Bahnhofstrasse. Klar, hat man immer. Aber dann ist es schwer. Und dann kommen ganz viele namibischen Köche und Autoren und Schriftstellerinnen und sagen, hey, habt ihr nicht auch eine Strasse für mich? Namibia, wir sagen mal Folgendes, falls ihr noch eine Strasse offen habt, nennt sie gerne die Smisma-Strasse. Wir wollen ja weg von Deutschen. Die Smisma kann ja auch irgendwie so wieder kolonisieren. Überhaupt nicht. Ja, aber wenn es ironisch kolonisiert ist, dann passt schon. Also wir bieten euch an, sowohl die Stefan-Tietze-Strasse als auch das Podcast Ufo-Strasse,, falls ihr noch Strassennamen braucht, Namibia. Und ich habe gerade nachgeschaut, in Book of Mormon fahren sie nicht einfach nach Afrika, sondern nach Uganda. Und tatsächlich in der zweiten Folge von das große Das Podcast-Ufo-Antenne Afrika-Spezial nehmen wir mal einen kleinen Ausflug nach Uganda, einem fantastischen Land in Afrika. Und die liebe Anne hat uns einen Beitrag geschickt, was man sich unter Uganda vorstellen kann.
Viel Spaß mit Anne und Uganda.
Hi ihr beiden. Ja, nachdem ihr letztes Mal schon was über das südafrikanische Namibia erfahren habt, dachte ich, frage ich mal meine Freundin Uganda, ob ihr mir noch mal ein paar Sprachnachrichten zusenden könnt.
Und da ist allerlei zusammengekommen, ihr könnt ihn mal reinhören,
und vielleicht bringt euch das das ostafrikanische Land etwas näher. You're practically breathing life. Yeah, people are lovely, the nightlife is perfect, the party never stops. Well, I would say it's one of those countries that's so welcoming. You have the locals who open, like, welcome people with open arms, and we treat foreigners, sometimes I would say, even wir die Werte haben, dass sie sich bei Hause fühlen. aber die Stadt wächst immer, die Schmerzen, die Liebe.
Kampala ist generell gut. Kampala ist full of happiness. Also die schnappen sich einfach Motorradtaxi und auf geht's. Daneben gibt es aber natürlich auch allerlei andere Verkehrsmittel.
Aber die Bodabodas sind wirklich eines der bekanntesten und auch mit der unsichersten.
Also regelmäßig sterben dadurch super viele Menschen.
Aber gehört einfach zum Chatbild dazu, deswegen gibt es da ganz besondere Spezialitäten. In Uganda, zum Beispiel, haben wir eine spezielle Sache, wir nennen es Rolex. Es sind nur Rolled-Eggs in einem Chapati, Freude-Eggs in einem Chapati. Es ist wie ein Delikasie. we have that special thing we call it a Rolex it's just rolled eggs inside a chapati fried eggs
inside chapati it's like a delicacy everyone buys it it's in every town setting every
district or anything any society will always have someone who does that because it's a very
easy thing to make it's quick it's for starters, the proteins and all the stuff that come with eggs. We have so many local dishes, as every tribe has their own dish, the common dish being grasshoppers, locally called in Senene, that fall in November of every year to March of the next year. Seasonal, but a common delicacy,ikasier, der von der Majorität. diversified with beauty and truly gifted by nature, habitable, friendly and hospitable,
with 56 tribes and nine indigenous communities.
In Uganda, we have 55 tribes,
and every tribe they have their own language
and their own culture, like a dancing culture.
Because we have different tribes, every tribe they have their own language and we cannot understand each other. In Uganda we have like our own central language called Luganda, but this language is really difficult, even us in Uganda, some of us without speak, we always use it and mix it with English so the central language luganda make us to communicate i am an obisoo by tribe so i speak logisu we are famously known for our culture our culture has our two has two things that we are known for uh kadodi which male circumcision. Our circumcision is not medically induced, it is as old as one thousand years or more. This means a man who gets circumcised is transitioned into a man. For you to become a man, you must have been circumcised, so boys become men. This process is not bound by age, you can become a man at the age of eight. Für alle Naturwäuschen unter euch gibt es auch eine besondere Artenvielfalt, das zeigt auch schon das Wappen von Uganda, man kann da so ein Kranich sehen und auch eine Antilope, es gibt aber noch ganz viele verschiedene andere vom Aussterben bedrohten Tierarten, zum Beispiel das Nashorn oder auch die grosses Berggorillas. Speaking of River Nile where the Swiss is actually here with us, the deepest lake in Africa, Victoria, mountains to hike such as Renzuri, Elgon, Moroto, wow, I could go on and on and on bad. I don't have all day Uganda. Make time, visit, explore, adventure, fall in love, perhaps you can even settle down here. Good for you and for everyone. It's better when you come to uganda you you see
a lot a lot it's not a big country it's a small country but it's really a lot to learn and a lot
to see but most importantly all that aside investment and all that ugandans are really
friendly and and you find that you you of course when you go like to any other country, you want to get affiliate acquaintance with certain locals, so you feel safe.
In Uganda, you'll almost be safe with everyone.
I wish you a nice day, a nice everything you're doing, your relatives, your friends, your family, greetings from John and my family. Also sechs Streifen insgesamt. Ja genau, aber halt auch in der horizontalen, die belgische Flagge einmal umgedreht quasi und dann verdoppelt und der Kranich in der Mitte. Ich finde das so geil, dass sich das Land entscheiden kann, einfach ein Tier auf die Flagge zu setzen, einfach zu sagen, ja schon Kranich, oder? Kranich ist ein cooles Tier, hat eine coole Form. Also ehrlich gesagt, ja, habe ich wieder sehr viel dazugelernt. Ich wusste nicht viel über Uganda. Nee, gar nichts. Uganda ist auch das Land, um das es, wie du schon sagst, um Book of Mormon geht. Ich glaube, Armut ist da wirklich ein grosses Thema. Also wenn man Uganda mal die Google-Bildersuche anwirft und so, ist es schon, glaube ich, eins der Länder, die man mit dem europäischen Klischeebild von Afrika in Verbindung bringt, was so die ersten Bilder sind. Zum einen Giraffen in der grünen Steppe und auf der anderen Seite dann halt die vollen Städte und sehr viel Armut. Aber ich glaube, es ist total interessant, was andere gesagt hat, also auch, dass man nach einem Land, was man gerne mal bereisen würde, irgendwie auch. Ich glaube,
lass doch mal einfach alle Afrika bereisen.
Ja, und wir haben unser erstes afrikanisches
Gericht gelernt, Rolex,
also gerollte Eier,
es ist wie so eine Art
Ei-Hotdog eigentlich, oder? Ich habe es so verstanden,
wie so eine Ei-Tortilla oder
sowas habe ich eher verstanden. Ah, okay, ich habe mir so
wie so ein Hotdog vorgestellt, dass man das Ei so rollt
und dann so wie so ein Hotdog in so ein Brötchen tut. Weiß ich nicht. Kann man bestimmt auch googeln. Ist bestimmt lecker, macht das doch heute einfach mal. Überrascht doch eure Familie mit einer schönen ugandischen, ugandanischen Spezialität. Da hört man auch. Tatsächlich wurde, wir machen ja eine grosse Colony Watch, wir gucken, wer hat da kolonialisiert. Ja, die Colony Watch. Und tatsächlich waren es, glaube ich, in Uganda in Anführungszeichen nur christliche Missionare, die da unterwegs waren. Das ist ja auch Binnenland, das ist ja nicht ans Meer angebunden. Ich glaube, für Kolonien waren vorrangig wahrscheinlich die am Meer. Das weiß ich nicht genau. So weit würde ich mich nicht aus dem Fenster lehnen wollen. Nee, ich auch nicht. Lass sie wieder aus dem Fenster zu machen. Jedenfalls müssen wir da nicht dafür sorgen, dass die deutschen Strassennamen wieder umgeändert werden in ugandanische Namen. Ja, großartig. Freut mich. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was da weiter noch kommt. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, weil du es auch gerade gesagt hast, so dieses Armutsklischee aus Europa, dass wir in der Schule, in meiner Schulzeit haben wir ganz viel Geld gesammelt für Togo. Ich weiß nicht, ob das auch ein Land ist oder eine Stadt oder was genau, aber wahrscheinlich ist es ein Land. Und das weiß ich noch genau, dass das ganz oben bei uns in der Liste stand, dass es immer hieß, dann haben wir irgendwie so Zeug verkauft und dann haben die in Togo irgendwas gemacht, so Handketten und so. Ja, das ist eine Straße Westafrika. Haben uns das geschickt und wir haben das dann verkauft und denen das Geld geschenkt und so. Und da war ich auch mal dabei, weil dann konnte man sich so ein bisschen vor Unterricht drücken. Togo sagt Danke. Das würde mich auch mal interessieren, also falls jemand spezielle Infos zu Togo hat, mich würde mal interessieren, ob das gut gelaufen ist, also ob wir die achte Klasse des Grafinger Gymnasiums, die aus der Armut, helfen konnten oder nicht. Und auch viel Kleidung ist immer schwer bei so einem riesigen Land, auch mit Wohltätigkeit. Wo fängt man an, was macht man zuerst? Ich kann mal empfehlen Coffee Circle, da bestelle ich mir mal einen Kaffee, die unterstützen da kleinere Dörfer. Mein Kaffee kommt zum Beispiel aus Äthiopien, und ich glaube, es ist sogar ein biologischer Kaffee, der da einfach so wächst noch.
Und dieses Dorf da rum wird dann von denen gefeatured und kriegt dann eine saubere Wasserversorgung und so weiter, es wird in Bildung investiert und so weiter. Dafür ist der Kaffee ein bisschen teurer, aber ist vielleicht ganz gut.
Wenn man in solchen Kleinigkeiten des Lebens, weil man besieht ja viele Lebensmittel usw. noch dann doch aus Afrika, kann man vielleicht mal ein bisschen verbinden einfach. Ohne viel Aufwand kann man, glaube ich, was machen. Aber wie du schon sagst, es ist schwierig, wo fängt man dann an? Aber es ist, glaube ich, dann doch gut, irgendwo anzufangen. Und ich würde sagen, weil es ist wichtig, die einzelnen Länder Afrikas zu kennen, wir machen das jetzt wie dieses Gedächtnisspiel mit dem Ich packe meinen Koffer. Wir müssen jetzt immer alle aufzählen.
Wir zählen Afrika auf und ich beginne mit Namibia. zu kennen. Wir machen das jetzt wie dieses Gedächtnisspiel mit dem Ich packe meinen Koffer. Wir müssen jetzt immer alle aufzählen.
Wir zählen Afrika auf und ich
beginne mit Namibia. Wir zählen
Afrika auf und ich fahre fort mit
Uganda. Musst du nicht erst Namibia wiederholen?
Ah ja, mit Namibia
und Uganda. Okay, bis jetzt haben wir
zwei. Es wird immer schwieriger. Mal schauen, ob wir
alle 55 kennen. Aber ich glaube, wir
kriegen das hin. Bis jetzt Namibia, Uganda.
Ihr könnt alle mit uns zusammen alle Länder Afrikas
lernen und irgendwann haben wir alle durch.
Genau, das ist wichtig, weil man weiß nichts.
Das war es für heute. alle 55 kennen, aber ich glaube, wir kriegen das hin. Bis jetzt Namibia, Uganda. Ihr könnt alle mit uns zusammen alle Länder Afrikas lernen und irgendwann haben wir alle durch. Genau, das ist wichtig, weil man weiß nichts. Dann machen wir auch so ein Lied. We are Africa. Sehen wir nicht. Gut, vielen, vielen Dank an Anne, vielen Dank an das Intro von Kim und vielen Dank an alle weiteren Einsendungen, die wir noch bekommen werden zu Antenne Afrika. Haut rein,
tobt euch aus,
gestaltet die Beiträge auch gerne
kreativ und wild und
tobt euch aus,
wie gesagt, und wir freuen uns über alles.
Haut rein, macht's gut, bis nächste Woche.
Ciao, ciao.
Und für uns den Wild, glaube ich auch.
Ciao.